[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum guys thanks for
listening uh you know you guys for the
most part listen to every episode if
you're here for the Phelps Brothers I've
become good friends with these guys
they're fantastic human beings
this is such an open and honest
conversation you're gonna have but
before you listen I would just ask you
if you like this episode and you're like
hey I like the interview I want to
listen to more of this guy we've got so
many great interviews and I hope you'll
you'll tune in and uh subscribe we're on
all the platforms
um at inside of you podcast on Instagram
and Facebook at inside youpod on the
Twitter
and um we really talk about mental
health and life and so many other things
and if you uh would like to support the
podcast more I'd appreciate it subscribe
write a review it helps tremendously and
if you really want to support the
podcast if you you know more than
anything join patreon patreon.com inside
of you there's tons of perks but you
give back to the show and it helps us
produce the quality shows that we want
and that you want and that's patreon.com
inside of you perks like getting your
name shouted out every episode perks
like zooms with me perks like uh YouTube
lives with me perks with uh merch
discounts and uh behind the scenes all
sorts of fun stuff uh packages sent to
me and signed by me I give little gifts
and things like that anyway
um I hope you'll join also the inside of
you online store we've got awesome stuff
like sweatshirts and tumblers and
Smallville scripts and all that jazz so
check that out and I'm on the Cameo and
doing a bunch of cons so look on my link
Tree on Instagram at the Michael
Rosenbaum you can see where I'm going
where Tom Welling and I are going uh
come to an evening with Michael and Tom
that we do in cities and sun's been my
band lastly these are the new tumblers
if you go to sunspin.com you can get one
of these they're pretty much badass but
more importantly we're playing a show on
September 16th Saturday at 5 p.m love
your uh your company and we'll shout out
the questions and names and all that
stuff we play music there's prizes zooms
it's great music I hope you'll enjoy
September 16th 5 PM go to stageit.com
type in sunspin or just go to
sunspin.com and get tickets I really
appreciate your support great guests
Ryan how are you I'm all right you're
all right yeah yeah still going to
therapy still going to therapy yeah a
little stressed a little stressed Life's
a little bit in flux right now but I'm
I'm doing okay it's like everybody's
kind of feeling like that it's a it's a
weird time it's a weird time I don't
know why in the industry especially
Mercury in retrograde is that a thing
I've never said that before in my life
what is it actually mean I have no idea
yeah great well I hope uh things get
better for everyone everyone including
you guys out there I hope you're taking
care of yourself your mental health and
uh trying to exercise trying to do
things differently Breaking Bad Habits
all you could do is try one foot in
front of the other and uh being good to
yourself is is a big part of it
um Phelps Brothers
you guys know him from the Harry Potter
movies
um they have a a another show a reality
show they're doing together a travel
show which is awesome and they got me to
do a travel show so John heater and I
Napoleon Dynamite geez why are we
traveling we're doing a show called
scared and we go to the creepiest places
in the world and there's my little puppy
hi Charlie look how cute Charlie come
here Charlie hello uh I love these guys
I've hung out with them many times and
it's always a treat and they really get
deep so let's get into Oliver and James
Phelps also known as the Phelps Brothers
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode in any we air
before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
there aren't people in England supposed
to look older
for their age
like Greece their romance being high
school
right yeah
that is very true that is very very true
um what a treat having you guys I last
time I saw you was Australia
yeah it's um
yeah I know we spoke about doing it then
so yeah it's great to be able to
actually sort it out finally I know I'll
be able to uh be able to get things
going it's awesome you got yeah it's not
easy to to pin you down because you're
doing a lot are you guys still doing the
podcast normal not normal still are you
still doing that are you now just doing
the travel show
no at the moment it's just the the
travel show because simply because well
you know how you obviously know how much
work goes into making podcasts and all
that kind of stuff
um whilst we were traveling as well it
was quite a long time uh when we're away
from our especially when we're at home
uh we're away from our families enough
that we kind of wanted to be at home
like actually at home instead of
actually I'm just going into the office
for a couple of hours yeah exactly so I
was just talking uh before we started
recording by the way I never call you
ollie do you hate Ollie you have to hate
it no no it's actually what most of my
mates call me to be honest so it's all
good Ollie and Jimmy or Jimbo what do
they call you
uh do you know I've got so many
different people call me so many
different things
it's uh it's quite funny do you have
this like different people where you say
you filmed in different locations or you
spend a period of time
do those people know you would obviously
they know your site different ways
people from other parts of so my powers
in London call me like Jim my my best
marriage that's from Uncle me Jay my
Pal's here call me Jimmy
people I know
yeah so whatever you want to call me I'm
good okay so here's the video no
um yeah it's funny because yeah my uncle
will go Mike he'll call me Mike my
uncles will call me Mike my dad will say
Michael
my mom will say Mikey some friends will
call me Rosie some you know it's like
it's just all over the place but uh what
a boring start to this conversation
um
now look you guys do a lot of stuff
together I mean obviously how many Harry
Potter Potter movies you did 11 is it 10
or how many uh
did eight it seems like it seems like 10
11 years yeah eight years you did that
together do you guys it I mean I have
you know John heater who we had dinner
with Napoleon Dynamite he's a good buddy
of mine and um you know he has a twin
brother Dan and they can say
the same thing at the same time they
will they think alike they like the same
thing everything is is like wow they
there's minimal differences in these
guys with these guys what about you guys
are there bigger differences or do you
hate to say that there's not a lot of
differences but what are the differences
um
say
no no not not to the point of obviously
the guys because
yeah as you say they're very
um
probably more connected maybe in that
that frame if you know what I mean like
the Finish system it's Central saying
the same stuff at the same time
um I think there was probably a time
when we would do something very very
similar to that probably the more time
you spend with with each other maybe you
get like that but I think another
Tendencies we're very different in terms
of
you know in terms of like
uh how you how you think how you how you
perceive yourself how you interact with
other people as well maybe there's a
difference there
like there's
um yeah so I think I think you do see
differences in in that and it's quite
funny when people may look at you and
think oh they must they look the same
name is that the thing and said the same
thing and it's quite funny when after a
while you speak to someone and they say
oh yeah you guys are quite quite
different in terms of you know you're
more chatty in this scenario whereas
you're more laid back in that scenario
yeah there's differences all around
what about you James because I always
perceive when I meet you guys you're
both really friendly and open and smart
and you're good with the fans I see fans
even coming in at when we went to the
little bar after dinner and they're
coming to you they don't recognize me or
heater or anything but they're just
going straight to you guys the Weasleys
and I'm like you know these guys
are popular but you're always so
friendly and open but I definitely see
and tell me if I'm wrong James is a
little more reserved than Ollie
is that true uh yeah two would you go
well and I'm I'm very much I'm more than
happy at times to be an observer kind of
thing like I
um
I I enjoy like surveying the room and so
then what's going on and then kind of uh
chip in with a a comment now and then
so what's the most um I was really I was
reading a book years ago and it it was
very like I can't actually remember the
title of it now but I remember the the
lead character was kind of always aware
of people who don't speak a lot but when
they speak you listen more if that makes
sense so I always if I'm meeting new
people I purposely try and do that so
I'm not over
over me them you know what that's really
funny to say that because
now I know why no one listens to me
it makes perfect sense I'm always
talking everybody steps to the rule we
can you can hear you coming that's all
right I guess Alvin City don't listen to
me I think I have you know good ideas
and things and they listen but uh you
know sometimes uh yeah I I see that but
it's nice that there's a little bit of a
difference like that you know
um I think it works for your show and
what's what's the name of the show again
travel show you mean the Fantastic
friends travel show
it's just fantastic friends yeah so um
you think about it so we we wrap season
two and
um I was gutted we couldn't we couldn't
get you on this one I know the date's
sort of aligned for that one but we'll
do it we'll do it
we'll get there one day um yeah so we we
wrapped on that recently so now in the
post-production stages
um but it was it was really cool we had
a lot of fun and
um those guys who have seen the first
season
um
pretty much much more of the same where
we go to different locations with a new
guests every week and it's a lot of it
was trying new things so I'm more of
like I would rather go in a
you know I'd rather jump off a bridge
and some something something silly like
well something adventurous and
adrenaline pump like that whereas
Oliver's a bit more he'd rather go to
find a nice food places and um yeah more
culture and uh the guests would normally
be somewhere in between so we kind of
want to show that you could go away into
a new place but actually
if you're with someone else you do
things which you wouldn't necessarily do
before and that may be something that
may be the highlight of your trip right
necessarily realize that would be it
it's kind of like a married couple in a
lot of ways you got to compromise
because you know Oliver likes to do his
thing you want to do your thing so
you're like all right well go to your
thing your art gallery we'll check out
some art and then we're gonna go
skydiving you cool with that and you
kind of work it out there I mean is that
sort of the way it works yeah yeah kind
of I mean we were the way the concepts
came about
um a couple of years ago I remember
James my we had uh appeared at a
convention in Colorado
and had a really great weekend with
everyone there I think it was like the
Fourth of July weekend so it was a big
big weekend type festivity type thing
and afterwards James needs Powell um
wanted to go
um by water rafting and they were
climbing to mountains and stuff and I
was I was going to try we were doing
things
we were going to do the the 14ers we're
going to do a load of the 14 000 feet
mountains around the Rockies in Colorado
and white water rafting and all that
kind of stuff
so they were they were down to do that
and I was about
I don't know if you were there actually
at that convention when we were there I
kind of think I was because I remember I
just remember being in this car on the
way to the airport with you guys once
and you were telling me about it is that
right yeah yeah because we we just I
remember like literally about a day the
day before I flew out I was in a pretty
gnarly car accident
and in hindsight shouldn't have gone but
anyway that's a different story and I
was like after the after the show I was
like oh god well I won't do the white
water rafting or anything like that but
I'll come I'll come down
it's just south of Colorado Springs so
ended up doing the monitoring class
which was just not fun it's like
literally climbing Railway completed for
yeah it's one of those things when you
do it you're like okay this is great but
I don't know how people do it more than
once that was the way I perceived you
know I look over and James is actually
buzzing
it's literally a it's literally a
a mile up
like straight up and it's at times it
gets to like 80 gradient so you're
pretty much scrambling up there
uh ladder I don't know obviously because
you're in Colorado I remember doing that
I'm just thinking uh I don't know if
that's do it because I've got like
really bug in my neck before I'd like
you know three broken ribs or something
but if I I don't want to do this again
I've done that and um and then
afterwards James I don't know I
published the hotel down the road and we
just come from they say we've been in
been in Denver so in a nice hotel
metloads of nice people and we were
literally staying in this Motel
um like side of the road job like 19
cash for the place to stay there
overnight you know the type of place
where you've got to move the closet in
front of the door when you go to sleep
oh yeah
and I was thinking
I know people think we obviously look
the same but we're definitely different
when it comes to this because this would
not have been the type of place I would
have I would want to stay you know to
books do you remember the hotel though
yep all the wrong reasons I don't do you
remember the one in Denver the nice one
in Denver you don't remember too much
but you remember that one so that's the
memory
much better things than fear of my
safety but anyway
um the and then afterwards I was like
there's got to be something in this
because and it just shows the two types
of trouble you can have you can have a
high end or a low end or a adventurous
or relaxing or a cultural or a whatever
so we we picked that idea around and
eventually we we landed with the guys
with Dash pictures and they they really
dug it
um and then we thought well let's get
someone else involved so it changed so
each episode is not just us going and
it's just uh in a different place but if
you've got a different guess and that
can totally change the dynamic of of
where you are and what you're doing you
know and yeah and then said like we've
just finished a second season it's been
it's been awesome looking looking back
at it
and also looking back is how sometimes
I'm still doing stuff but really not
wanting to do some of it but you go
along with it because you're only there
once and you
sometimes you'll actually keep turning
you think that was that was bloody
awesome doing that that was fantastic
inside he was brought to you by Factor
meals listen do not fast forward this is
something that you are going to love I
promise you I love it it makes my life
so much easier it's Factor meals cook
your meals in like two minutes and they
are so delicious I had this chicken with
this mashed potato cauliflower and uh
green beans and I was like wow I don't
even like it tastes so good and you can
get whatever you want they have so many
items at factor and you're not spending
a fortune getting delivery you're not
spending a fortune or wasting food in
the refrigerator when you go grocery
shopping I love these guys factor is
like America's number one ready to eat
meal kit and
um there's a reason for it it can help
you fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door you'll
save time eat well and stay on track
with your healthy lifestyle adjust your
stride this Autumn without missing a
step choose from 34 plus weekly flavored
packed fresh never frozen meals ready to
eat in two minutes too busy running
around during the day to think about
lunch keep your energy up with lunch to
go effortless wholesome meals like grain
bowls salad Toppers that are ready to
eat when you're on the go no microwave
required looking for calorie conscious
options during the busy season try
delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with a round or less than
550 calories per serving need an extra
boost to help support your Wellness
goals and feel your best as you tackle a
busy Autumn try Protein Plus meals with
30 grams of protein or more per serving
and they've got all sorts of stuff Ryan
assortment of 45 plus add-ons breakfast
items like delicious apple cinnamon
pancakes bacon and cheddar egg bites
potato bacon and egg breakfast skillet
or an easy Wellness boost try refreshing
beverage options like cold pressed
juices shakes smoothies this set
September get factor and enjoy eating
well without the hassle simply choose
your meals and enjoy fresh flavored pack
meals delivered to your door ready in
just two minutes no prep No Mess head to
factorymeals.com inside 50 and use code
inside 50 to get 50 off head to
factormeals.com inside 50 and use code
inside 50 to get 50 off that's code
inside 50 at factormeels.com inside 50
to get 50 off inside of you is brought
to you by prize picks this is a new
sponsor and they gave me uh an account
well I had to sign up for an account
which was easy as hell and I was able to
do a little fun betting on things and
what's great is it's it's the easiest
and most exciting way to play daily
fantasy sports it's just you against the
numbers instead of battling thousands of
other players including pros and sharks
you either pick more than or less than
on like two to six player stat
projections and watch the winnings roll
in and I did it and I was like I'm not
gonna know how to do this I was like oh
so last night there was a Atlanta versus
the Dodgers and Strider was pitching and
I said oh he'll have more than five
strikeouts and then another player and
you go oh and he'll have less than five
stride and I won I won 40 bucks huh it
was that easy so you know it's it's so
much fun and if you're not getting into
these fantasy things that everyone does
and I'm kind of not really that
knowledgeable on that stuff this is fun
it's easy it's on your own time you
could really win some money and you
don't even have to bet that much much
prize picks is certainly the most fun
I've had winning up to 25 times my money
this football season you select two or
more players pick more or less than on
projected stats and place your entry
that is it prize picks is really simple
to play I could pick my picks and submit
my entry in less than 60 seconds Ryan
yeah you can test your skills and you
could turn ten dollars into two hundred
fifty dollars like that players can
choose from a vast selection of sports
and Stat types not offered anywhere else
they can even pick in-game projections
after a game has started which includes
halves quarters periods and more guys
this is fun it's so easy for prize picks
to just get the app get on board you put
a little money in your account and even
if it's five bucks 10 bucks 20 bucks and
then you see what happens you might want
to watch a game now to see if someone it
makes things more exciting it really
does and for me I'm not a big better I
have friends that are
you could either be a big better or
someone like me who just does it kind of
randomly and for fun to see what happens
prize picks is currently operational
over 30 States and Canada not Ontario
prize picks is the best way to have
action on the game in States like
California Florida Texas Georgia and
over 70 percent of the U.S uh it's just
a blast I know you're going to try this
because like me you want to kind of win
a few bucks here and there don't you
okay this is it this is how you do it
folks you want to have some fun you want
to bet a little you want to make a
little money easy none of this
complicated fantasy football stuff this
is the way to do it go to prize
picks.com inside use the code inside for
a first deposit match up to a hundred
dollars you must be present in certain
States visit prize picks.com for
restrictions and details prize picks.com
slash inside use code inside for a first
deposit match up to one hundred dollars
prize picks
you know what's funny is I can't like I
didn't think that was gonna be the story
I didn't know that you guys kind of came
up with this idea I I felt like it was
something that someone had to force you
come on it'll be fun it'll be this will
be that and James was like I don't know
I don't want to do this and like but you
guys really were the ones who were
spearheading this thing right
yeah it's well it was like it's all
Oliver's brainchild I just happened to
be in the right place at the right time
to get the gig as well
um but it was it was yeah it was one of
those things where we we kind of we knew
what the con like the concept that we
wanted and we were very lucky to to work
with guys that had the same vision and
all right we've met a couple of of
um people on the way who have kind of
said the same thing that you know go and
follow if if you have an idea on a
project back yourself and do it and it's
it's not that we put anything
um you know we're not jeopardizing our
livelihoods in doing it but it's
generally like we believe in the project
and and we're very lucky that it's gone
down really well
um around the world actually I've So my
gym I go to here is um it's owned by a
load of Polish guys and it's quite a I
don't really fit in shall we say I'm six
foot three about well I'm 88 kilos I
don't know what that is in pounds I just
know that that's a lot of Coke
um a bit a bit leaner shall we say
um and and the guys in there aren't
they're they're very big
anyway this guy Waddles over to me one
day and he said oh I was backed out the
shadow appeared across me as I didn't
and he said um I was back in Poland at
the weekend visiting my family and my
niece said you're gonna have to see this
program it's about these two English
guys that travel
and the show's on HBO Max in in Poland
and then he said all of a sudden I see
you and I he's at my gym
my niece wouldn't believe me so I had to
have a photo with this like guy his name
is literally tank as well so it was it
was very bizarre like I didn't think of
that kind of thing he even he said like
it's not something that he thought he'd
enjoy watching but he genuinely enjoyed
it as a a family show as well now be
honest with me or are there times when
you guys and be honest where you're just
like oh my God I'm so tired of him all
right would you shut up I don't want to
hear him and you're just smiling on
camera going because you're brothers and
you're like you you do so much together
isn't there those moments where you're
like oh my God shut up James oh yeah it
happened yeah I think but it was
happening regardless who you travel with
oh yeah but you know if you're
especially when you're away like on this
last season we did
um you know we did the best part of like
six to seven or seven weeks I think it
was straight
um so there's times when you kind of
just like
all right and I'm sure people a lot of
people on the crew do with me as well
they're like okay but you know for the
you kind of just you kind of do with
anyone I think everyone's been away with
somebody related or not and you're kind
of just like okay all right but then you
you kind of see I've always always
looked at like the bigger picture the
bigger goal as it were you know we're
not after a a um
Gallagher effect on camera you know
where we're just like calling each other
out and everything like that
um so yeah so we do you do kind of You
Are
I'd say semi-conscious of that while
filming but at the same time the
audience don't want to see that they
want to see people enjoy themselves see
hang on hang on I don't know if that's
look you don't want to become some kind
of like you know Norm what's his name
I think the truth is that you don't want
it to be two or come I do we never
wanted we don't want the show to ever
come across as to Stage TV yes yeah
those type of programs where there's
like oh there's some random drama going
on or something like that right but but
what's fun but what's fun I think is
like seeing you know like you know James
says some snide remark and goes yeah
yeah but then he goes up somebody needs
an app you know like a little thing like
that just um you know keep those little
nuggets to give a little bit like all
right they get annoyed with each other
every once in a while isn't that perfect
there's a there's a few of those nuggets
in there around they're hidden but
they're in there they're in there which
is which again is like keep it keep it
natural you know that we didn't want it
to be I always remember years ago when
we first were looking to get the show
made
and we met with this one production
company and they were like hey wouldn't
it be so funny if like you lost your
luggage like no no it wouldn't no it's
almost like trying to try to script it a
bit the good thing is with the show one
more thing how how crap would that be as
a travel show because it'd just be you
calling one of the airlines saying it's
all right Michael's very important to
them but my suitcase is currently in
Miami and we're in
well it's look it's really enjoyable
show and you guys are very Charming
obviously
um you're only in your third season what
guess just name a few guests that you've
had on on the show so people can go back
and watch those so in the first season
we so we've again workers were the exec
producers on it we can kind of
uh we can have a good sign who's on and
who's not as well and
we want people on that you're going to
get on with first and foremost because
it no matter how much how how much
acting comes into it you can't replicate
a good rep a good relationship with
people on on camera right yeah so
um we're lucky that we've got a load of
our our Potter mates involved and other
acting friends of ours who's joined in
so in the first season we had Haley Joel
Osmond
um he came to Austria with us he's
actually an amazing snowboarder as well
wow that's what we learned that one
um and then there was Bonnie Wright who
played our sister Ginny in the movie uh
Vana Lynch
um Nat 10 has come with us on the this
season I went to Turkey which was pretty
epic
um yeah so we've had some pretty cool
pretty cool guys guys and girls come and
join us and it's you know if we do
season three obviously you're gonna be
the highlight oh yeah oh yeah
from uh Arias Arya Stark you had her on
oh so yeah did you have Matt Lewis on
too already
um
we were down uh there's there's quite a
story to that actually so Matt
um in his wisdom the day before we
started filming
um
tweeted
where he was
and said Can is anyone here know where I
can watch the Leeds United match oh my
God and we and so James and I just
traveled from England and to get to
where we were was the best part of over
30 yeah
36 hours from door to door
so you get you get into this hotel lobby
and there's there's people there that
won't say hello and everything like that
Lewis
yeah and then we get to watch leads as
well who the hell wants to actually
leave yeah lose we're watching that he
was just like
I'm still sorry mate I'm still sorry
wait a minute leads you can't put leads
down didn't you get your audition for
Harry Potter and leads we did what about
the football team not the city the
city's beautiful
good good uh good response
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
how are you guys not doing this this is
with the world the way it is
um the stigma there's not stigma on
therapy anymore everyone's talking about
mental health and life and this is good
and this means that you deserve uh
therapy uh for your life in your life uh
it should be a part of everyone's life
if you ask me it's helped me
substantially and uh you know you could
talk about so many things and if you
don't they get bottled up and
unfortunately when they get bottled up
things start to manifest and they become
some other things and uh you know if you
just keep talking to someone as a
professional not me but talking to a
professional you'll see the benefits
quickly anxious thoughts you know
sometimes they they don't seem like
they're going to go away and uh when
you're trying to go to sleep your mind
racing when you're on a date you're
anxious there's all these things but
talking through them with a licensed
therapist through better help really
will help you Ryan you still work with
Better Health I do and it's been good it
has been good for me yeah I've noticed
you get you're calmer I always feel
better coming out of it I mean I had one
yesterday and I usually uh
supports me through you know the next
until the next time I talk yeah and you
always feel like you have nothing to
talk about and by the end you're like I
can keep talking always always every
time therapy and better help give me a
place to get out of my negative thought
Cycles so I can find some mental and
emotional peace if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's all done online just fill out a
questionnaire which takes you a minute
and get matched with a licensed
professional therapist but you can
change them if you don't like them
um at no additional charge it's so easy
it's convenient it's flexible it's it
works to your schedule folks get a break
from your thoughts with better help
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest innovation
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection do you remember was
it your idea or I mean how old were you
and whose idea was it to for you guys to
audition for this we were we were 14
when we first auditioned and we we
learned about it because my mum's friend
got in touch with her and just said you
know what they're they're doing uh open
auditions for The Potter movies
maybe maybe Oliver and James could go
along you know so we went
we thought yeah sure why not it's on a
Thursday so it's like we missed school
we get possibly to be in the mate in you
know a film
and one experience so we thought well
we've got to lose so we we went up to
these which is about about two and a
half hours from where we grew up
and at this hotel
um they were auditioning for every role
so it was just
yeah there were thousands of people
there like going for all roles it's like
you know kids with lipstick lightning
lightning marks on their forehead days
really pushy show parents you must be my
daughter you must seem like that and
we're just there like we turn it we
suddenly real so you get like a
a raffle ticket
obviously swinging your raffle when your
numbers could you go you guys could do
the audition and then we stood down
after about 20 minutes or so I couldn't
even realize that we all realized that
we were the only set of identical twins
who weren't wearing the same clothes
which
in hindsight you think yeah you need to
look the same you'd go dressed the same
but this is how green we were to be the
whole process so we we darted across to
the
um to the department store over the road
and then bought just matching shirts
and wear it
and yeah and then we we eventually got
seen probably about three hours later or
so I'd say
um did our one line which was it was one
of Harry's lines I forget the exact line
and then yeah it literally did that and
then they're like right okay off you go
thank you very much
a couple days later we got a phone call
um saying yeah we'd love to see the guys
at the main studio just outside of
London and we fax you the the side but
it's even before email and I'm gonna
listen before emails really available to
everyone so they would practice the uh
the slides and then yeah that happened
about three or four times after that
where we were after we met um Chris
Flemington director David Hayman who
produced it and
and a couple of the other like casting
um people
and then we had a we were then we went
away on a family vacation which was to
pull through or Crete one of the Greek
Islands now for two weeks we were like
okay and just first before we flew out
they said oh yeah we'd really like to
see the guys when they get back
and we're suddenly like right okay so we
know that gingers don't pass
so we were you know back to 100 living
under a umbrella the whole time trying
to stay out of the say I'm getting any
color
um and then we went back landed and then
the next day we went to our screen test
which was like on a on a set like
everyone everyone most people do you
know you did a screen test in front of
the tea with the chemistry is like on
camera
and then yeah but I think the next day
or the day after they
um John Hutchison who's the head
coaching director called my our house my
master and she said hi is that uh is
that the mum of a friend George Weasley
and then that was it so it's a whirlwind
probably six weeks in total I'd say but
mad mad life changing event I mean did
you guys even want to act when you first
started were you acting
did like it wasn't a thing which
whichever I never saw it as a a viable
option of
a career and so much so the the Drama
teacher at our school said don't take
drama for your essentially High School
level because you won't have a career in
it
um wow so I had great to like going back
to him after that summer and be like
well you know nothing how about this I
actually I actually told that story when
we we did um
one of the theme park rides have been
open at Universal in Florida and I told
that story and a couple of weeks later I
had a tweet from a a kid who went to my
who goes to my former school and said
this video has now been banned from
being shown in class because everybody
keeps playing it when said teacher was
like giving his advice on a situation
and they're like well you don't know
anything like this
excellent oh my God that's it's just
insane I mean when you're when you're
doing this audition you're like hey the
first one you're like all right all
right but when you got that next call
back
did you start to like every day you were
obsessed with it thinking about it and
it kept going and going you couldn't
stop thinking about it
it was weird in my head in my head I
kind of already assumed well we've got
this in my head at that age I'd suddenly
gone like yeah we've got this and then I
remember it wasn't long after The Truman
Show movie had come out and I had this
weird like maybe this is just like a
whole thing
hear that and it was like everything's
rolling too perfectly
um and then yeah I just I just always
assumed that we were going to be Fred
and George
in the film it was a bizarre confidence
that I've never had before James did you
feel that
I found it I mean I I had nothing to
compare it with it was it's always where
it felt like it felt like you can
imagine I mean like I guess it just came
an actual thing where you imagine
yourself in the role
when you're doing the audition because
that's good for the audition but
um yeah without you saying with every
other audition because I was like five
or six of them in total it gets more
real and it get and you know that you
must be doing something or actually
further downline and I've never been the
one nervous in all my life than when we
were in that
um screen test
because the use is touching distance at
that point I mean you've been there many
times so you you know you know that it's
it's reachable
that's what scares you when you're
thinking about it like you know oh my
God this is real this is real how do I
stay I mean and you're 14 how you don't
know how to keep it together you don't
know how to act cool you don't and I
think that's probably the charm that
maybe you guys have yeah
you know I think so I mean the one the
one thing I did remember from the screen
test is because obviously our hair is
Weasley Ginger that we ended up having
when filming and they try they were
trying a a temporary hair dye and I
remember they put it on I thought this
looks
just like you know I've got slightly
light and brown hair but this isn't
going to work maybe we don't look
let's make sure and then
so but you kind of like push that to the
back of your head I suppose when doing
it but it was just I remember when they
when we got the uh got the roll I can't
even remember if they must have
mentioned it but I can't even remember
them mentioning that they were gonna die
ahead
I just remember just it was like an
unsaid thing
wow well I remember them saying I
remember uh I think it's Chris Columbus
saying to us and you guys are okay with
your hair being dyed right so you can
shave my head for like it you know you
know that's like that yeah I know what
it is my God I mean did you read the
books or obviously you read the books
after for sure or the book I don't know
how many books were out there I'm not a
big reader but uh you know did you ever
were you like wait a minute
we're in the books you guys are there
throughout the books right
so
yeah so the first audition happened and
the fourth book had just come out and it
was the first like publicized midline
midnight launch of a book in however
long because obviously the books were
they got I always say they got a new
generation reading around the world
which is so that's why the the film was
going to be a big thing
um and we'd read the first book so we
knew the characters
from the first book but then I started
reading the second and the third book
over that summer
and
the third book so I wrote in the prison
of Azkaban which I think is my favorite
book out of the sea out of the series
and you know the smell that a book has
right
um that smell no matter what book I'm
reading now reminds me of reading the
Prisoner of Azkaban in the summer of
2000 when we were casting the roles
and it's just just little things like
that yeah wow
that so I mean you you knew like hey
unless we get fired we're going to be in
a lot of these movies this is
or did you kind of think you were just
we kind of yeah we kind of kind of knew
they were going to do two films
initially
and then
yeah and then it kind of just rolled and
then there was always talk or maybe
they'll do
a third and then they'll maybe do a
fourth and then if that goes well
because really at that time I think
Potter is still
I might be wrong I mean obviously you
got the marble University that's totally
different
genre film type thing
um I think it was the first time saying
that I remember that you've had eight
movies which have
Dade and then if anything grown in
popularity normally it starts then maybe
the second one maybe yeah aggressively
worse usually
yeah so so this was this is something
that I remember where it had never
happened you know and certainly where
they're still the buzz and it gets
louder and louder and you it was it was
always funny though because like I mean
when the films would come out
I would get recognized
regardless like where I was I get
recognized and then gradually it would
slow down so I was like okay cool and
then for some reason when the last book
The Last film came out it's continued
it's continued ever since so it's a it's
a it's an amazing thing that there's
there's still kids to this day who
weren't even born when the last film
came out yet they know every word in the
film and know everything about it it's
such a special I mean it's the gift that
keeps on giving you you do something
like that
and that is just like you can't beat
that you can't beat the Harry Potter you
know world I mean to me it's like being
in the Star Wars the original Star Wars
world or something like that it's it's
probably yeah it's it's at least that
it's just it's remarkable and I always
thought you know I when I saw Harry
Potter I always thought is this what
England's really like is this I you know
I kind of wish it was you know I guess
there's some place with the cobblestone
in the little buildings and things but
was it kind of like when this the books
came out was it sort of like the Willy
Wonka from the original Willy Wonka
waka's releasing new boss he's opening
up his Gates
that was a kind of chaotic and
crazy and the books wouldn't stay on the
shelves
I think it was I think it's like the
world right what worldwide for uh for
the books um I know that in the states
it was a big thing about the the
midnight lodges as well and all that
kind of stuff so
it was always a thing then when we
caught when we were filming obviously in
the new book would come out we'd want to
know what was going to happen with our
characters so that was always a quick
one of who could read it the the fastest
or
or just get the audio book like some of
us did and listen to it on the way into
work and when you're waiting around so
um
you kind of knew what was happening with
the character and what the their Journey
was going to be and that kind of stuff
what was who's the one person you were
an art of or were you too young to
really be Star Struck
there's quite a few I remember the main
the first person who I was suddenly like
like white eye like wow
um and that was we were at the read
through
um we sat down and uh sitting next to me
was Rick male who is cast to play peas
and unfortunately he didn't
if the character didn't make it into the
films but
growing up like uh rigmo is just like to
me a comedy God in terms of
acting stuff like very over the top very
in your face humor slapstick or you know
lots of other stuff and he I remember I
was just like he made a little hello how
are you nice to meet you I'm Rick you
know and then
he went to write um he wrote in a book
of mine
um and he said Oliver the best actor
I've ever crossed it out worked with
best message and
you know it was just it was just a real
Icebreaker and we did the the line where
we have today uh
uh honestly when you call yourself our
mother and his Facebook he's supposed to
get a laugh and he was exactly the
thought he would be like watching on the
TV everyone was like apart from Rick who
was like
[Laughter]
great what about you Jim
uh I mean to us there's there's too many
to say because it was literally like a
who's who of of British acting
throughout the whole season I bet your
parents were probably more Starstruck
than you guys were at times
they definitely knew more of obviously
more of the more of the character like
more of the actors um because we knew so
like Maggie Smith for example we knew
are more from Sister Act
wow do you know it so and she and she
would actually say that to us as well uh
at the time but yeah she was incredible
because I always think that
I learned obviously you you learn like
you pick up obviously what the what
others around you especially more
established acts are doing around you
but I always remember how they were
behaving off camera
and there's a reason why all these
people have been working for so long and
they're so respected because they treat
everyone else with respect wow and there
was no deavery moments that you could
see like they would they would always be
there on time if they needed they'll go
they'll sit they'll wait they'll go and
do their thing and some of the some of
the uh stories as well which Michael
Gambon would tell
he was he's one of the funniest men I've
ever met and if everyone gets stuck in
the elevator with anyone
he's probably the person because he's
got so many good stories and there was
one I thought a story before but there
was um
on the sick film I was an A.D
so I always wanted to work on the crew
um you said I want to work on the set
yeah
and they were like you can do this right
you're not gonna you're gonna work hard
you're gonna they had you had to really
because I think they knew they kind of
knew that
um you know my work ethic was there and
all that kind of stuff and I'd done a
few days on different jobs with the crew
before all right but I was contracted
for the whole picture but I was only
gonna be needed for about
uh two weeks or something out of nine
months so I saw I just said I swear it's
an agent and I was like right um I'm
gonna ask them to do this instead
instead of like getting me well paid
work I'd rather dude I'd rather go and
do this and so I I went there and I was
a key set PA and so that's my I actually
got my credit on the film so that's why
my my favorite credit anyway wow that's
cool we were we were filming um the
scene when Dumbledore is up the clock
tower without giving too much away it's
a very
um important part of the whole story of
the of the series
and in between takes Michael was was
outside
um having a cigarette and I was just
with him looking after him as it were
make sure he didn't run off and he was
he said to me so what are you doing at
the weekend and I said well actually
Oliver and myself were reading Peter and
the Wolf with the Halle Orchestra in
Manchester
um
but I've never ridden with an orchestra
before so I'm not sure how to you know
how do you speak in time with the music
and all that kind of stuff I'm not about
an eyelid Michael's like oh I've I've
done that before that kind of stuff he
got the script with you I was like yes
so really she sat down with me and went
through well this is where the music is
going to come in pencil that do this so
I've literally got dumped and he's
dressed as Dumbledore telling me all
this as well so he's he's talking me
through it so I've got this absolute
Legend just and he I mean he's you think
in is in full right to be preparing for
the sin he's about to shoot but he was
all about you know giving me that time
to do that and
um it's it's one of those where I've
never forgot that and I I always think
that there's a like I said there's a
reason why good actors work so many
times yeah and it's it's it's just so
you look a lot at a lot of the great
actors and there's look there's some
real out there there's some
monsters you hear the stories but for
the most part the big ones are usually
the nice ones that have been around a
while they get it they're you know uh
you know they have nothing to prove
there's this sort of like let that go
and it's like hey let's
pay it forward and uh I mean I gotta ask
about Alan Rickman because you know he
was just legendary but he seems to me
from what I've gathered and talked to
people he was a kind man on set but he
was also you know if if anyone you would
fear a little bit or be nervous around
some some of the guys or gals would say
Rickman was a little intimidating but he
wasn't a jerk or anything what did did
you just feel that presence like hello
what is it tell me a little bit I think
it's obviously he was in
which carries its own oh you know
presence about it but no I mean I mean I
always remember he um he came back from
an awards in the Oscars or somewhere and
he got an iPod and it was one of the
first iPod Nanos or something like that
and he was like I've got this iPod and
we're in there and making he's like how
do you how do you make this thing work
and again like it's he's like in full
PayPal for it we're dressed as like Fred
and George in their school outfit and
we're there we're there but I mean
you've got an iPod
um
but that was that was the type of person
he he was I'd say like there wasn't the
like these guys were young they need to
talk to them there wasn't any of that
going on and there was other stuff which
it's not my story to tell but I've still
I've seen him uh when we were filming uh
really helped one of the
um there was a girl who was doing a
um yeah she was a double and she was
doing a project for her school and she
was looking for someone to voice it and
he helped her out with that or there was
something like that I forget the exact
the exact um details but stuff where you
were like that's Cloud That's a classic
that's cool that is cool
um
do you guys still want to do a lot of
acting or what like you look you have
families now you got you know you're
taking care of people the little people
and you know you know you're traveling
and doing this show I mean do you like
to be as busy as possible or do you sort
of like the lulls where I could just be
with the family I could just be with the
kids then I can go work
um or are you always looking for new new
things to do and always uh needing to
keep busy is that important to you for
me for me I I'm I don't feel the same
when when I go away I kind of flick a
switch and it's like I can't think about
home
because
I'll say I'll miss the family and I miss
walking the dog and all that kind of
stuff in the morning so I kind of flick
a switch and I'm just like blinkers on
what I'm doing when I'm away and I'll
check in once a day with what's going on
so when I'm when I'm home I'm home
um but I do I do love to work I love the
whether it's scripted stuff whether it's
the semi like the
um
documentary stuff or anything like that
as well like I I really enjoy the
process
um so I guess I I'm happy with both I'm
am I I'm in a fortunate position as well
where I'm not needing to go and work
every day
um which is a very I'm very very lucky
to be in this online so which definitely
helps
um but I mean I'm I'm always and I've
got a very supporting family my wife's
amazing that she's she she knows what
the job entails like I was I was like
this when she found me yeah and and she
she's cool it's very supportive so so
yeah um I love working but I also love
chilling out as well so it's um I'm very
lucky in that regard I always you just
say the same
I'd say yeah I'd say the same I mean
it's one of those things like you're
always looking to do stuff
I think that's the the healthy way to
look at it always be open for things and
and when stuff does appear if it's if
it's workable then definitely I'd rather
do it than find an excuse not to do
something obviously there's some things
you get and you're like that it's
rubbish on the whole on on the whole
you're going to just be going for it I
mean there was well there was one like
where you I remember getting this this
offer through and it was
the pay was bad the script was even
worse and it was like nah now I'm all
right you know I can I can pass this one
by but as James said that's only because
we're very lucky because there's a
there's a great fandom from Potter which
has been able to help us yeah that's
awesome it's saying that that thing you
know and and pursue stuff like like the
travel show like the podcast and things
where we can really help
yeah did I either of you guys ever deal
with any kind of anxiety or depression
or were you guys pretty much even killed
was it you know was it a pretty good
upbringing was uh you know what was that
like and and how did you deal with it if
if you did so yeah
I'm
I'm very I'm very lucky I'm I'm a very
um I was just thinking actually your
last question when I'm home I'm still
very busy so it's not like I sit around
and get bored like I I've I'm always out
I'm pretty much always Outdoors
um either
paddle boarding or golfing or hiking or
walking or it's cycling any or actually
doing the London Marathon this coming
weekend so I'm exhausted
yes have you done a marathon no oh no we
had a Marathon gas station and I used to
stop at
but what about like but what about like
you know you say you're busy and you're
doing all these things it sounds like
this is what you have to do it's in your
blood like I have to do this and that
keeps you sane
I think so I think that is because I've
never done I'll speak to my friend about
it the other day actually like I've
never done therapy or anything like that
and I think it's because I don't feel
like I've I've needed to because that
that is my thing like I can
I guess a form of meditation for me is
unless you out on the water with my dog
and we're just paddle boarding and
it's just like that's that's it could be
choppy waves it could be it still isn't
a pond like it's it's I'm just happy to
be in that moment and even when I'm
traveling my uh I was I was taught this
exercise years ago where I'll find
somewhere Outdoors
could be in the middle of the city it
could be in the middle of a forest and
I'll just sit down close my eyes
and listen for five minutes to what I
can hear
and
then you obviously the more you listen
the more you can hear then you open your
eyes and try and picture put pictures to
the sounds and wherever I do that I
always feel like my batches are
recharged and I'm good to go with
whatever any anxiety I've got seems to
have melted away in doing that and I
pretty much do that every day every day
I like that I'm gonna start doing that
is it okay if you go in your backyard
right near where my dog poops and just
sit there and there's a chair yeah no
maybe it should be somewhere else away
from your home no no well it literally
works because even if you're in Garden
you're here similar sounds or completely
new ones and then it may be a new sound
you'll be like what the hell's that I
like that Ollie
yeah I mean I'd say I'd say the opposite
to be honest with you in terms of what
I've gone through it quite quite a lot
over the last probably
um
what seven years maybe like bad
um I think it kind of triggered with
that uh when I mentioned that um car
crash I mentioned earlier that was kind
of like a trigger too
like a bull rolling I suppose on on the
mental health side of things and then
probably about a couple months later
I've never actually spoke about this uh
in depth but um yeah and then it
gradually got more and more I'd uh our
daughter had been born and I was
worried about the man I was going to be
in terms of the father and stuff to
build all that he had like the times
I'll be going to put it to bed and I'd
be like
I'm I'm gonna be a bad dad probably I
can't do yeah I mean I can't provide for
it maybe the way she needs to or
whatever like that and you you stuck
down yourself with that then you have
other things and it all came to a head
where I was I was literally driving home
one night uh from London
um on a Motorway and I was just like
aimed at the end of the road and just
like let's go and call it
I'm religious so to me it felt like God
literally bitched like me and said get
home and
and I did I like this you just I can't I
can't remember the right thing all I
remember it going really really dark
really quickly
um but I got I got back and um checked
myself into into a therapy unit the next
day and that started to address it which
was and it's still and the ironic thing
it was on world mental health day that
was a really ironic thing I was like I
got I I got home and I was Googling like
you know um I was Googling uh you know
mental health and all the topics about
world mental health then I thought me uh
yeah and then anyway
um and then gradually started to talk
some stuff out and then it's been a long
process it's not it's not by any means
like it gets done yeah and you can have
people stay all the time oh he's good to
talk you know find someone talk to
someone you know and that's easier said
to them but the best way I describe it
is
and if anyone's listening to this and I
understand what I'm talking about is
you're aware that many people go through
it but to you it feels like you're the
only one who is and I know finding that
you know and it's finding that it's
finding that that way to to reach out I
mean even even recently as last week I
was I was in a really dark spot last
week you know
um through through some things that have
gone on and it's how you how you deal
with it I mean my my wife is brilliant
she's being brilliant with me and really
supportive and I've started being uh
um actually it's psychiatrist now so you
there's different obviously different
ways of treating them
you can have a counselor you could have
a therapist you could have a certain
psychiatrist you it's just different
different tools to deal with stuff and
how to how to get back to yourself and
how to
I always want to make sure that I leave
the world in a much better place when I
came into it and if that if that's me
helping people do stuff in terms of okay
well he's he's the man he always comes
across a really positive outgoing guys
yeah and for the most time I am but then
you know it won't wear the mask you know
to stop themselves from doing doing
stuff and and sometimes maybe that's
where the
the
comic comes out shall we say yeah
because nothing hides fear nothing hides
fear or tears more than Allah
you know you you do that and then you
you kind of have to have to live with it
and there's there's ways of doing it but
like I say as the time last as recently
as last week
when it just didn't feel like I was I
thought if I cry now I'm not going to
stop
and it's it's just one of these things
you just have to
first of all acknowledge it I think
that's the most important thing is to
acknowledge it see it not that it's a
weak to see that it's not something that
is
it'll be all right pull yourself
together
um and also the amount of mate who I who
I've spoken to about it
recently or or many weeks one month year
gone by
there and they'll say
yeah I know mate or or even worse
they'll say to me
you could have told me you really could
have told me then they get really pissy
but I didn't think if I mentioned it but
then it goes back to what I said is that
you feel that you can't you feel like
they wouldn't want to hear it
but I mean like even
uh like last week um
oh sorry yesterday last night I went and
met it with one of my oldest friends and
we've known each other for years and
years like you know years I was best man
at his wedding
um Godfather to his to his kid and he's
he's he's having a chat about some stuff
he's going through and we just went I
went with her he lives near the
countryside
um and we just went for a walk for about
four hours and it is cold here at night
at the moment but you just you know we
found a tiny little Country Pub we went
in had a pint
been in another walk and just put the
work I wouldn't even say put for the
world to write we just spoke about stuff
which is going on and
it's literature they say you know a
problem shared is a problem hard but
then you also get
the thing he says something to me and I
went I often I know exactly I've done
the exact same thing which he set up
really
because sometimes you who are you
holding yourself
um I always think who are you holding
yourself
at the leveler
you know we've uh my daughter and I have
got a saying which is be your bear
and she's at it then forget the rest so
it's that it's that thing about it
because at the end of the day style of
being the best version of you and then
worry about whatever other people are
doing yeah you know I'm so glad you
opened up about that because it's like
you know all so many people listen and
they you know you guys opening up or you
know what helps you James and then
Oliver which I was surprised I thought
it'd be James if we had the depression
I'm just kidding no is that because I
like this is that because I like to go
outside at night with the telescope
yeah no but um you know Ollie to be
honest with you I I've had those moments
where I'm driving in the rain and I
remember
well I was doing a show and I had to
drive over this bridge and just thinking
I'm so tired I'm just not I'm not in my
right mind and just
what am I doing here I just I don't know
it'd be better if I was gone I I've had
those thoughts I'd be better I'd be I'm
a burden I'm no one understands no one
knows what I'm going through they no one
you go with that because it just you you
do feel that isolate you do feel that
alone and you wonder why it's happening
to you and what happens is with me is I
would be envious
of my friends going out and having fun
oh my gosh why can't I go out and have
fun
why do I feel like this why do I gosh I
wish I was that person they're just so
they have Clarity and they have you know
you never know what other people are
going through
no and that's it and it was it was funny
when you say like the whole they have
fun think because the thing what really
got the thing going with me years back I
say this is
2 20
17 I think it is
a while ago anyway long time ago now
um but yeah and I remember we went to
[Music]
um
I was noting I was going to places then
realizing that I wasn't having fun
it was like going through the motions
going through the motion exactly exactly
exactly so we were we were we were went
to watch iax football team playing after
that and I'd always wanted to go to the
you know see them see them play and we
were sat there and we were guests of the
club in the Royal box we had Henry of
Anderson who is the
um like an amazing legendary goalkeeper
in his own right but also a like the
director of football director of the
club there chairman of the club or
whatever
he presented us with nine shirts from
the team we met the team
and I remember just sitting there
thinking like I should be enjoying this
yeah and you like obviously you don't
let yourself do it and then going back
to when we're in in the car
um that came from we were coming back
from playing a golf course which is like
one of these super duper Elite golf
courses you need to know someone just to
be able to play that that type of place
you know we
and I was driving home thinking
I don't know if I'd be able to play
there again I don't know if they'd want
me to play there again and you just kind
of start thinking that and then other
things start going through your head and
to the point where I didn't want to
I didn't want anyone to think that I
drove up there intentionally
because I was like well
then they don't have to worry about
you know a note or maybe I'm at fault or
anything like that because you think
well I'm just better if I'm not around
at me and like get home and it was
um it was the start of yeah just just
start of taking the ownership of what of
what you do one step at a time man
that's what it is you have to just take
that first step
yeah you can go you can go backwards you
know as you said like as recently as
last week I went to bed for like I don't
know how long I was in there for but I
didn't want to get out and you you work
your way through it yeah and you know
it's important like now that you know
those feelings it's important to tell
your wife like hey I'm feeling like this
there's nothing you could do but you
just be there and just know that I'm
trying to you know or uh James by the
way I'll just asked you really quick
quickly did do you know any of this was
happening was it a complete shock to you
when he told you
uh I could I could tell certain things
um but
it it obviously he sat my mum and dad
and myself down and kind of explain what
was what's going on and all that kind of
stuff yeah yeah
well I I guess I'm on the other side of
it because I don't go through like I I
haven't had that that dark cloud over me
in in such a way I at first I found it a
bit
uh I couldn't relate to it yeah if that
yeah which
which is is a learning thing as well
it's and obviously like I I can now I I
hope for myself I'm not that's the wrong
that's wrong
I'm I'm uh
try and put yourself in in Oliver's
situations and and thoughts on other
people's as well if they're talking like
that
um because just because it never
affected me and there's a lot of I guess
it's like a lot of uh conditions like
that it's if you've never had it it's
hard to to understand yeah I agree with
you 100 I think it's like you know um
having a bad example analogy would be
like you know I would I had a lot of
back surgeries I had a lot of back pain
and my friends were like oh sorry to
hear that man oh cool cool man you all
right oh good you're feeling better yeah
man I'm fine all right yeah yeah and
then
one day one of my friends comes like
crying to me and I'm like uh are you all
right like dude my back's been so messed
up and I just thought of all the years
and all the surgeries you had I I had no
idea how debilitating this is and people
don't know until they feel it they don't
and so all you could do is say I love
you I'm here please come to me when you
need me anytime and that's it I love you
I don't care we'll get through this it
doesn't matter about understanding it's
just understanding that it happens to
other people and it happens to many
people and if it's not happening to you
that's thank God but you know yeah yeah
exactly I mean I remember I was in uh in
Japan once and we were uh sorry I were
in South Korea and so we'd uh we've done
an event in Japan and a friend of mine
came out and he he we went to to Career
afterwards and I told him about it this
was a couple of years afterwards and I
said to him about you know I was I'm
talking seconds from from crashing away
like over 130 or whatever the car was
maxed out at the time and he said uh
he's just very simple thing he just said
well I'm really glad
and that is always she said what he said
what
he said I'm really glad that you didn't
and it's just a simple thing but yeah
it's just you know and and sometimes
they're the things that people
feel really supported with more than
oh well you know and the worst thing you
could do is come on first few I'm
feeling bad the worst thing you could do
is say to them yeah I've done that or or
or come on man look at you you're you're
in a franchise you do these cards people
love you you travel you have money
you're good looking you're like you're
like that's what you don't want to hear
it's like I here's the thing my friend
said that said this at his wedding he
said
um
most of my life
intellectually I knew people some people
loved me I knew that
intelligently
that they love me
but I never felt it I could never
feel that
and then he met his wife and I could
relate to that because I know so and so
loves me how I mean of course I've known
him forever and we've been through they
have to love me but there's a difference
between like
yeah I know that and feeling that and so
you know that's important because
sometimes we're just like you just feel
so alone so anyway thank you for for
talking about that that's just like and
by the way you could always call me man
because I've been I changed man I didn't
yeah I didn't I didn't realize it was I
think when would you tell when did you
mention it you know what I mean by when
do you when you mention it like that but
like I said I've never I think I've ever
gone into depth with it like that before
so
um yeah I just wanna I'm sure when
people talk about stuff it's the normal
thing to say but I want to Echo that is
just that if anyone's listed this right
now they will because I remember when we
did that I remember when I did our
podcast someone said uh someone drop me
a message saying that they were
um they were having a one of the worst
days of their life and they just Gotta
Laugh out of our podcast so thanks for
helping them out but it made you feel
next door is just one person listens
that right now and says I'm gonna I'm
gonna yeah I'm feeling a bit like that
I'm getting that way talk to someone
just talk to someone talk to a therapist
anyone your best mate start with that
amen start with your parents that was
someone thanks for sharing all right
this is it Phelps Brothers talking
with the Phelps Brothers this is rapid
fire this is from my top tier patrons
they ask questions patreon.com inside of
you I love you guys you keep the podcast
going Leanne I've heard many identical
twins state that they would switch
identities for a bit did either one of
you do that what is a common
misconception people have about
identicals so rapid fire go go Ollie
first
rapid fire uh yeah I have
um switched identities with James once
when I forgot my driving license and so
I borrowed it
James
there's one which I'll tell you off
camera
oh okay
Alice switchy switch
a little twitch
I've I've tend to be Oliver at a hotel
so I could sign all my
um expenses back to his room
I can see that happening a lot all right
Heather see what was your all-time
favorite Weasley twin shenanigan over
the course of all the movies
uh the the joke shop in the sixth movie
that was my favorite uh because the set
was amazing and it was all about us
which every actor wants her
yeah all right Ray H how do you feel
about working a projects together versus
projects individually
um you've already really talked about
that but rapid fire uh are you guys
gonna continue working together you're
going to continue doing this series uh
you know uh you'd like to do things
individually and work together is that
kind of like how you feel yeah I'd say
I'd say the second I think definitely
working together is is great it's a good
thing to be able to do but also working
individually is always it was always
nice as as your individual self to do
that is both important as well you agree
James
yep very much so Marisol what was your
least favorite scene to shoot on Harry
Potter whether it was just hard it was
long it was boring ugh
there would be least favorite scene
quidditch in the third movie because it
was it was blues or green screen and
these things can take a while anyway
because they need to match up with all
the other uh effects that are going on
but it was set in the rain so we were
soaking wet we had a giant like fan
blowing at you what made you look like
you're flying so that was cold
um yeah that's I feel get shuttered when
I think about it both physically and
metaphorically James
uh least favorite probably would be the
uh
sixth movie when the Weasley house is on
fire because that was night shoots for
about
two weeks
and it was cold and wet and all those
kind of fun things which no one realizes
goes on when you're filming guys this
was awesome guys I hope you enjoyed it I
know it's late in England
it's like probably 10 10 p.m I know
you're gonna get ready for bed yeah
but it's been it's been great yeah I
love it thanks for being so open and
honest and always fun and uh I hope to
see you guys soon
take care all right cheers
thanks for getting so personal I had no
idea this was gonna happen yeah I just
was so
proud of the conversation that they
shared with us yeah and their feelings
and life and a lot of people don't want
to open up and when they do they don't
realize how many people would help so
guys
thank you thank you for being here
um
also as you know uh we continue this
podcast but we can't do it without you
so if you love the podcast you want to
give back join patreon.com inside you
I'll write you a message after and uh it
really helps the show keeps the show
going and going I get my own guests and
I got Ryan here and Bryce and and Jason
without this perfect team um it's kind
of The Perfect Storm without one of them
it's just uh not it wouldn't be as good
but we want to keep them around and I
want to keep doing the show so
um there you have it so thanks for all
your support and love throughout the
years some of you months
some of you days new listeners
um if you want to find out all the
information about me where I'm going the
band uh cons just go to Instagram the
Michael Rosenbaum and go to my link tree
link and it shows you everything where
me and Welling are going to be Cameo all
that stuff so I hope you'll uh hopefully
I'll see you around and uh thanks for
being here anything else Ryan really not
really now here now we're here we're
doing it we're doing it we're we're
doing this thing called life
and now it's time to read the top tier
patrons whom I couldn't do this without
you know who you are but let me remind
you of who you are Ryan why don't I say
uh uh patreon.com inside you become a
member get your name shouted out tons of
perks packages sent to you but why don't
we uh I'll do a voice and see if you
could mimic oh boy okay posture
Leah and Kristen let Alicia Yukiko Jill
e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Raj C that was pretty good
Jennifer Ann Stacy L Jamal f
Janelle B like e El Dan Supremo
99 more Santiago M Chad w v n p Maria
and
Brad d Ray H Tabitha D Tom and Talia m
hi Michael it's Dave Hall Betsy D Angel
M Rhiannon C
cool okay Dave Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy d
what's another accent we can do
Sean Connery
oh yes now I can't really do him
lovely all right how about um
let me tell you something Brandy D Joey
M Eugene and Leah Corey Jacob B
itch
Angela F Mel s Christine s barricade
Shane R Andrew M Tim l
Amanda Arden gen B Kevin e Stephanie
cage or L jam and J Leanne J
now it's uh sports announcer here's the
pitch on the way Luna R base hit to left
Mike F there's a double to Center Field
Stone H makes the play it throws over to
Brian L and Kendall L retires all three
batters
kerosey's pitch on the way to Jessica B
Jessica B Skies it to Kyle F on right
field Kyle Marisol P coming over from
Center to make the diving catch throws
it to Kaylee J and dabs the runner
Mickey L at second wow that was some
game I'll tell you Brian a has a
fastball that you just can't seem to hit
uh we've got Ashley here Ashley F Ashley
what do you have to say well this is
actually Marion Louise L Romeo B here
actually I was talking to Marion
Veronica Q
uh Frank B we'll just get done with this
gen T Nikki L April R Cassie B Derek and
jdw Michelle L kombbomb Ginger
Ginger Insomniac Ginger Insomniac Rachel
D we love you guys thanks so much for
the support and love as always we try to
have fun we try to give you something
special every week I'm Michael Rosenbaum
from the Hollywood Hills in California
Little Wave
and uh be good to yourself
damn it be good to yourself I'll uh I'll
see you next week
[Music]